yes I was on a show called scrubs I'm
not a doctor although I played one on TV
it was so much fun to do it it was eight
years and even a ninth year and now it's
incredible that all over the world
people love the show so it gives me
opportunities to come to great places
like this and to meet enthusiastic fans
and I love it so much yeah
now you played a doctor so long do you
ever have to stop yourself you ever in a
situation where suppose this is there a
doctor in the house leaping forward and
say yes me yeah I try I mean people
assume that I know things about medicine
and I know nothing and recently I've had
a series of surgeries unfortunately like
I and the doctors talked to me as if
they know I understand what they're
saying so I had a knee surgery a
shoulder surgery a elbow surgery penis
reduction surgery I'm kidding I never
had elbow surgery but they do talk to me
thank you tonight they talk to me like I
knew things but I'd know very little so
what's been the secret do you think of
your success in scrubs is a great
character that everybody loves to talk
because he's not aware of it but the
joke is at his expense and so there's
nothing mean-spirited about that
character and he just has no
self-awareness it's sort of annoying
that I'm an actor talking about my
character and the third tenser and I
apologize to that but there's something
funny about playing a guy who thinks
he's God's gift to women and who might
secretly be gay so there are a lot of
funny elements to it and he has like a
no understanding or awareness so
therefore I hopefully nothing that the
character I got was offensive do you
have any sense of how big it could be
when you start that first season oh I
knew how big it could be thank you good
night
I think the creator of the show a
gentleman by the name of Bill orange is
such a talented writer that he's so good
at marrying comedic moments extra
dramatic moments and I always felt that
I don't know he did a good job of
casting it it was a quirky little world
what everybody was funny on the show and
you never know but there was something
special when we shot that pilot episode
for sure and everybody felt it and was
aware of it so yes see obviously you get
recognized I get recognized a lot you
know I'm trying to create a new look so
I can play other characters but uh
you know there's just something funny
about playing the tots oh okay so when I
get recognized I this woman she
recognizes well and she says oh I'm in
the entertainment business too
I say great what he do is just like well
I'm a magician I eat and blow fire and I
said great my nickname in high school
was fire show me your act in a prayer
bridge okay then I said to her maybe we
could do a two-person show you could say
it on stage and say it now ladies and
gentlemen I will blow fire and then I
would walk out on stage and let the
magic happen you could be at any other
big comedy series which one do you pick
and which character which one appeals to
you you know I love watching comedy on
TV anything with Larry David that he
does or ricky gervais if I ever got the
opportunity to work with people like
that I just feel like I gravitate
towards funny people and so whoever the
funniest people are the funniest riders
the funniest directors I would like to
work with those people because when
you're around funny people there's
something contagious about it and you AG
each other on and you know there's not a
finite amount of comedic energy in this
world it actually builds upon itself so
I just like seek out comedic people
wherever they may be
you